like a number of british veterans scott
sibley is thought to have traveled to
ukraine as a volunteer to fight after
russia invaded
this week the 36 year old became the
first confirmed british death of the war
it's thought he was killed a few days
ago in southern or eastern ukraine
a second british man is missing
a foreign office spokesperson said
we can confirm that a british national
has been killed in ukraine and are
supporting their family we are aware of
a british national who's missing in
ukraine and are supporting their family
we are urgently seeking further
information
under attack from russia ukraine has
said thousands of foreigners joined a
call to fight with its troops
one british veteran on the front line
told sky news it's becoming increasingly
dangerous and said he'd not be surprised
if more foreigners are killed
yeah this is my old position
back in 2019 then sky news met two
british men who joined ukraine's army
before the invasion the true line over
there's the uh
enemy position
i'm married a ukrainian i've got every
much right to be here and the guys it's
taken me a long time to integrate here
uh
so the guys know i'm not
you know a war tourist or a war junkie
my family's here my family is 15
kilometers i can hear the shelling from
my front room but sean pinner and aiden
ashlin have since been captured by
russian forces
a senior mp urged other british
nationals to stay away
the government has been very clear
indeed all british nationals should not
be in ukraine
i know there's much discussion the vets
communities to want to do your part to
help fight but please do not go you're
not only putting yourselves in danger
but potentially others as well you might
get injured you might even get paraded
on russian television please do not go
to ukraine
too late for mr sibley who leaves behind
at least one child
a friend described the army veteran as
the bravest person he knew
it's not yet been confirmed why he was
in ukraine or how he was killed
debra haynes sky news